most all the films I've ever been in
I've played a mother but I hardly ever
play a wife I'm either divorced or
married or something really once I was
happily married mr. Donald Sutherland in
Alex & Wonderland now he turns out to be
Casanova I give you Donald Sutherland
an actor may act or a director may
direct brilliantly but if the cameraman
takes the day off we all take the day
off
it is the cameraman who decides whether
the Sun should be rising in the east or
setting in the West and what this does
to the performers cosmetic or the
author's literary intentions the
cinematographer tells the light what to
do and if he does his job well we thank
him for holding time still for keeping
it in proportion five years fifty years
eventually a hundred years from now
without him the camera is empty and the
drama is lost tonight the nominees for
cinematography are Haskell Wexler Bound
for Glory
Richard H Klein King Kong
Ernest glass low Logan's Run
olin Reisman network
Robert Serkis a star is born
and the winner is Haskell Wexler bound
for glory
thank you for this honor I want to thank
all the fellow workers on bone for glory
as all of you know better than anyone
filmmaking is a cooperative thing and we
had we had a good crew good people a
good film thank you